hello everyone and welcome to game
number 17 of the a 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael and
Michael Botanic and as the title of the
video suggests we are in for one wild
ride as you can see in the bottom of the
board
c7 c6 strictly speaking this is a
challenge
what styl means by this is that after he
played before on the first move bottom
again responded with c6 the caro-kann
defense stating that even though tal is
still two points in the lead botany is
not in any sort of a hurry to win back
the points he's behind in this match and
again he wants to see if tall will try
try to improve on his variations and if
he can get because basically in in any
in every game so far but when you got at
least an equal game with the caro-kann
it was only in in game number 15 that
Tull had like a slight advantage I won
the Queen's got off the board but it
wasn't enough for any any any sort of a
victory so d4 d5 Knight to c3 B
characters Knight captures Bishop to f5
so the classical variation once again
Knight the g3 Bishop to g6 and now
better to c4 again at the very sharp
variation tal says that in those days h4
was the most analysts move and it was
considered that h4 gives the white the
most advantage but the bots Finnick of
course knew that as well and the Tao
also says that there was also this very
interesting idea of playing f4 but f4
and only after black plays east 6 then
go h4 which kind of seems weird a
weekend in your king like this but it
does have a nice firm grip on the e5
square and if black is really unprepared
then maybe you can surprise him and I
was very happy when I read this as it
was some 10 years ago I played against
the I believe against the candidate
master and I want a very nice game using
this f4 idea so after Bishop to g6
Bishop to c4 Palace still isn't
interested in the f4 idea east six now
comes nice to e2 Knight to f6 now
Botvinnik goes for a different line he
doesn't want to play Bishop to d6 and
then a part with this dark square bishop
so here rather botany
with his light square Bishop Knight to
f4 by Tao Bishop to d6 attacking the
knight and now Knight captures an g 6h
capture son g6 and Bishop to g5 here
Bishop to g5 table wasn't very happy
with this move it's really not doing
anything botany can always go for Queen
to f4 into a f5 check the king and also
attack the bishop on g5 and then to all
we have to retreat but you know it's
giving basically black a choice to
decide what to do a lot of options here
so what eunuch decides Knight B to d7
not rushing anything we have castles
here although after the game tall death
consider that castles was maybe a bit
too optimistic
you know what meaning does have an open
H file for the rock maybe Queen to e2
followed by a queenside castle would
have been better so we have castles and
now Queen to a5 now attacking the bishop
and this is this is the critical moment
of the game not the critical one but the
critical one in tiles mind because here
and since you did enjoy that part from
the book in my previous video I prepared
another one for you so here in this
position Queen to d2 seems like the
movie want to play protect the bishop on
g5 also offer a trade of Queens but
again tal has the white pieces it's
moved 12 it's moved 12 you don't wanna
you don't want to trade Queens like
immediately
so here top played pawn to f4 and pawn
to f4 is in everyone's mind and had
thoughts as well it's like totally crazy
move and here is a part from the book
that I prepared and it also goes with
the title f2f for question mark and an
exclamation mark terrible anti
positional incredible White's last move
was so adorned by all the commentators
without exception with such epithets it
might be supposed that the player who
had white was absolutely unfamiliar with
any chess book that writes about the
game from White's point of view and it
is actually impossible to play like this
since the move f4 weakens the black
squares locks the g5 bishop autoplay
that's this guy here and and puts the
White King in a dangerous and
compromised position so yeah the white
King is on g1 the rook is
nicely eyeing that h2 pawn and now even
this diagonal is open so sorry about
that
so a very a very bold move this f4 but
even though everyone everyone said it
was it was totally crazy move not
necessary that it was totally anti
positional the engine actually likes it
so another thing tell-tell said that
what didn't have too much moves there
okay h4 was also an idea instead of f4
but you really don't want to play Queen
to d2 and this is a move Botvinnik
certainly didn't expect and now what
eunuch has to refute it over the board
and tal said that it took him some eight
minutes the decide on this f4 move and
in those in those eight minutes Tao also
considered a lot of things for example
one of the things tall disgusts is will
he be able to catch a movie with his
wife after the game so yeah so why not
therefore I mean it's the drowning hippo
all over so here botanique castles and
here botanique again accepts the
challenge as he quite castles Queen side
and now he will use the H file for
attack in the future district can come
to h5 maybe h4 double rooks and the H
file and start a very nice attack we
have a three that will of course prepare
b4 and here it's two botanique over 30
minutes so over half an hour to decide
on his next move and tal was already
happy with with playing f4 because if
Botvinnik spends half an hour on his
next move then that that's basically
worth it
here botnik played Queen to c7 another
idea
in botany could have gone for is c5 but
after c5 top could play b4 now attacking
the Queen and you don't want to capture
it upon allowing tall and open a file so
after Queen to c7 B captures on c5 now
you get Bishop captures on c5 and it's a
it's a pretty fine position for both of
them you can't capture the bishop if you
capture Queen captures with Czech picks
up the light square bishop it's a better
position for black so botanique
immediately goes Queen to c7 now c5
would be a threat as b4 doesn't come
with an attack on the Queen and as a top
pushes before immediately nice to b6
attacking
Bishop Bishop to e2 and here botany goes
for Bishop to e7 here the sum of some of
the commentators who shared an opinion
that if I was an excellent move for
black Italian his book didn't really
agree with this although it seems the
engine does agree with it because after
the variation talk we talk gives in the
book pawn captures Bishop captures and
Bishop to g4 check as you can capture
the bishop the point is pinned there's a
rook I'm the queen but Bishop to g4 is
an extremely strong defensive move and
this is this is move tall gives that
kind of says that this is why the
variation doesn't work for black because
now I'm talking to be 8c3 defending now
there's a rock captures on h2 King
captures Bishop captures on g3 with
check King moves and now Rock to h8 with
check you have to block this with the
bishop and now comes Knight to e4
threatening the c3 pawn and the F to
square Bishop to e3 defending here and
now nice to d5 attacking the bishop and
here this c3 pawn and it seems it's an
extremely dangerous position for white
you know just by looking at looking at
it you can feel the black is better but
you know seen it seems like too
complicated over position because even
after the game even after analyzing it
at all doesn't think that II five is a
word playing for black so Bishop to e7
Botvinnik agrees over the board that a
five doesn't work
Queen to d3 and now Knight F to D 5 C 5
C 5 was definitely an idea here for
botanique but again it probably spent
too much time he didn't want to over
calculate it 9 f 2 D 5 Bishop captures
on e7 Queen captures on e7 and now C 4 C
4 is again a move that requires both
units spent quite a lot of time thinking
about the variation but when he played
Knight to f6 and here at all was
extremely happy now he felt that his f4
move was was even even great because but
when he could have decided to go for
Knight captures on c4 and after Queen
captures on c4 Queen to h4
this could have been a dangerous idea
for towel and now you have an option
here you can't really play h3 with the
idea of giving back the piece because
now you're just lost night comes three
three your queen is the technology for
you have to move the Queen now Queen
captures you threatening Queen captures
and g2 with checkmate after Bishop
blocks now you get a rook captures on h3
and after you play Queen captures on e3
now you get to rook to e8 and there is
no defense against rook to h1 so the
only idea here after Queen to h4 is
actually to play rook to f3 and now
after Queen captures King moves quite
defended and it's a it's a perfectly
fine position for both white and black
so but when I decide not to do this he
played Knight to f6 and now we have rope
to be one Rock to be one is a bit too
over-optimistic a move as tile puts it
you have to protect the D pawn although
although you you kind of want to try
Todd let's say that he kind of he kind
of did consider a for immediately but
then Queen captures a five comes and now
Knight captures and c4 is a possibility
and here even if he doesn't capture the
piece immediately he can go rook to be
one now comes Queen to d2 Queen captures
on c4 but now comes Queen captures on d4
with Czech Queen captures rook captures
and Tom would be up a piece but
Botvinnik is up three pawns here tall
doesn't want to play this position
against botanique so like we said rook a
to be one but now what eunuchs simply
plays Queen to d7 threatens to capture
the d4 pawn with the Queen and here tau
admits his mistake of playing rook to be
one he plays rook to d1 but also gives
that if you play something like this
then rook to h4 is a very dangerous move
attacking the pawn and after you
defended Queen to c7 the fan attacking
the pawn once again and now you would
have to bring the route back rook to f1
and after Queen to d7 here you would
again either have to beg for a draw with
rook after the one hoping that botany
replies again Queen to c7 or you would
have to suffer in this position
so instead rook beat to be won
basically wasting the temple King to be
eight we have Queen to b3 now Queen to
c7 and a4 now preparing to pull those
pawns rock to h4 attacking the pawn a
five now 99th to f8 and now Queen to e3
defending the f4 pawn nice to e7 and now
comes Queen to e5 not really offering a
trade of Queens because captures and
captures would be practically winning
for towel because after rook captures
rook captures where do you go with the
night if you go to e8 you get rook to d8
check picking up the night so you'd have
to go rook to Knight to g8 so the
Knights protect each other but now you
get this nice to e5 move Knight to e4
move and after rook captures on f4
Knight comes here and the rock and f4
really doesn't have anywhere to go
unfortunately everything is protected
here all of these squares are covered
and the g3 is coming whatever you play
Knight to h6 you can try to bring the
piece into the game but g3 and the rook
is trapped you either have to give up
the rook with with rook to g4 for the
bishop or which rope to a 5 for the
night so a very tricky move Queen to e5
rook HT h8 and now b5 pawn captures and
now Queen captures he didn't want to
capture with the pawn he wants the open
B file and now he avoided the trade of
Queens as it is no longer favorable for
tau we have a six kickin the Queen away
Queen to be - and now rook to d7 an
excellent move that prepares doubling up
on the D file and also protects protects
the b7 point even more c5 and now a king
- a8 we have Bishop to f3 I'm that b7
pawn twice and now Knight to c6 and here
top plays Bishop captures on c6 he says
you don't wanna lose the strong better
but the threat on the pawn on d4 was too
great Queen captures now rook to f3
Queen to a4 and rook to d3 rook to b3
was also an idea about tal feels that
now rook to d3 is even better
rook to CH and now rook back to be one
now it's
it's very important to get some pieces
to the b6 square hopefully the rooks
botany plays Queen captures on a5
showing that botany even has time in a
in a short position like this to grab a
pawn rook to b3 now with this super
battery on the B file threatening to
capture on on be 720 c7 defending and
now Queen to a3 we have King to a7 you
don't want to allow any sacrifices here
we have looked to be six and now Queen
to f4 capturing a pawn if you go if you
play something like nice to d5 here that
that is possible to attack the rook but
it's too complicated after Knight to e4
a lot of complications arise and he
Botvinnik he decides not to do this he
plays Queen captures on f4 now he has a
lot of ideas like Knight to d5 Queen to
III check maybe even exchange in Queens
so nice 32 attacking the Queen Queen to
e4 and now Queen to b3 the idea of Queen
to b3 is checkmating both eunuch of
course now if you play something like g5
for example to actually see the thread
here the thread is rook captures on a6
and after you play this it's impossible
to do anything with black if you if you
capture then comes Queen capture some b6
King moves and after Queen to a6 check
roadblocks Queen to c7 Quinta CA this
would be checkmate on the other hand
after this rook captures an 86 if you
don't capture it if you're clicking to
b8 then you get rook a to be one a route
B to a one after night comes here rook
checks King moves now rope capture skin
captures and c6 and c6 wins the game
whatever you play you lose if you block
with the rook then rook to 80s checkmate
if you capture it then you get rook
check King moves and Queen B 8 this also
check mates so a very hard position for
botanics to defend especially in such a
time trouble
so after Queen to b3 botany played Queen
to d5 now the same idea doesn't work but
he misses one move here tall does play
rook captures on a6 botany plays King to
be 8 and now the idea of rook to
like in the variation we've shown
doesn't work because toss queen is under
attack
but here topless Queen to a4 this is
move $41 each time control and here the
position should have been adjourned if
botanique would would write it down what
movie will play tomorrow but
unfortunately as you couldn't find a
defense from checkmate he decided he
decided that he will not continue this
game and he resigned in this position
why did botanique resign what's the idea
here of Queen to a4 you can pause the
video and find find the answers for
yourselves
the problem is if you try to escape for
example I will show king to c7 then you
get simply Queen to a5 you have to go
back and rook to e8 this will be
checkmate and if you try a different
kind of move for example let's say you
try b6 to prevent Queen f5 check then
you get rook captures and after King
here to try now to escape to d8 now
comes the beautiful
rook rook the c6 check Queen captures
and now Queen to a5 again this comes
with check and you have to you have to
put the Queen in between the Queen and
and the king so Queen here and Queen
captures and b6 this will be checkmate
so yeah after going to a4 botanique
resigned the game and now Tallis three
points in the lead so already already
very close to winning that World Chess
Championship title so yeah a crazy game
a totally anti positional move a f4 and
a totally confused Botvinnik we're
spending spending like more than an hour
in the next couple of moves to try and
refute it but fails in time trouble he
he blunders between two d5 so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I do hope you enjoyed the part of the
story that that I added and yeah I would
like to thank Michael warden Joel may
she and Peter shock tell for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you all and I will see you soon